- okay here's the deal now we are really
back before last episode we were back
now we're really back why like a half
back that was a half back I'll Brokeback
Brokeback first of all today's episode
is sponsored by candid CO and quit we
love them and appreciate them so much we
are joined today by in the salaried
employee daily reducer Zac the sound
wizard hmm but he was a lad yes he's a
wizard he's not really a wizard is he
dance the Wizards the way we can't have
the competition here well how would you
title yourself Zac as a sound what you
see it's the sound lad blood does that
give you enough credit lad
I like it you like lad okay the lad is
with us here today why are we all
sitting here together because it's time
for 2019 Year in Review where we are oh
and Sarah go wonderful Sarah's out on
the switchboard in case you're wondering
who L is on the ones and twos who the
hell's backstage doing it today sorry
everybody listening are we back why are
we half back don't we have a limiter
dance with it like if I scream into the
mic it doesn't rupture yeah you could
just scream the whole episode no but
there should be a limit good impression
there's no magic it's gonna be yes there
is magic in limits the it's magic 2019
year and review the best and worst
moments of 2019 everybody we had so many
memorable moments we had some rough
moments we all had our shares of
hardships and triumphs here on the a
Street podcast and I thought it was
appropriate for us all to review
together
you know it's hard to come back from the
break with Jack and Eric I loved them
because I had so much I wanted to talk
about yeah Heello with you guys it's
been so long since I've seen you guys
and it was it was very difficult to not
talk about everything that we missed now
we have the opportunity and so I say to
you all we are back season 3 we are
ready
and all right did I say bomb the white
house in the last episode I did say that
nothing ever came of that okay The
Secret Service never came or anything
not yet anyway yeah there's no intention
of bomb what Zack had mentioned his
place but I think it was getting no
comment
scare me so before we get on to the best
and worst first of all let me ask
everybody how's everybody doing how was
your break Zack go ahead how was your
break oh it was wonderful super low-key
about the girlfriend night went to her
family on Christmas because I am a Jew
you're Jews he said she's a Christian
yeah going on she's look away if you
guys have kids how do you raise them you
know we had that discussion but we did
have that discussion so you know we
talked about incorporating both aspects
of religion which i think would be very
like a Jewish Santa Clause sure Jew for
Jesus Hanukkah bush okay yeah yeah we
we've had that conversation interesting
yeah and with our you bar about a Bar
Mitzvah I am a bar and what year if you
had a son would you want him to be a bar
mitzvah you know it's not that big of a
deal
I would you circumcise him 100 percent
yeah okay good so she likes what you've
done to your cosmetically she likes okay
excellent well thank you welcome back
sad happy to have you for having me in
how was your break I happen to know oh
not for me for a sec I was partying now
tell me
on Instagram publicly and then you also
put as you guys can see you soon critic
but not that cryptic it's uh it's all of
the the plain card suits would entertain
possibly that this girl here is the wild
card we're really coming in hot you know
this is my girlfriend can we confirm
that this is the wild card I mean kind
of speaking with the caption you know so
this is the girl who ruined I so wow
she's very pretty uh congratulations the
end she looks very much the bachelor
kind of worked it did work man did were
can directly maybe directly extremely
directly you guys understand the
bachelor Ian has a girlfriend we
anticipated but it did work yeah
there was little she went beyond the
chain of command yeah but no one worked
out great I'm she's very power yeah very
happy yes it's fantastic
she wonders oh she sees the ian's of
production
she is from she's not in state right no
no she's not here and you guys have
plans of we're uniting and we're making
it making it work I was there over break
visiting her and she visited me over
break I'm going back next month oh she's
coming back the month after we've got it
all with that how often are you guys on
the phone like every day you text her
throughout the day and calling mm-hmm
that's a good he's so smitten he walks
and every morning with a smile why
aren't you thinking any I don't know
discussion about like why am I still
getting [ __ ] for me why aren't you
thanking me this wouldn't be without
contract like what you actually broke
the continent by by saying well I'm
surprised
didn't try to bring up the contract cuz
I was ready to go to war now I'm not in
war mode anymore are you so we can tear
the contract he's in love you can know
tearing I think I think we have to keep
it for posterity
I mean I'm happy to talk about what I'm
up to things like that so you guys are
on the phone would you ever send her a
dick pic this is for me to know and you
never find out okay so I think that is a
yes because I've never sent a dick pic
although might I feel like I'm out of
that you should try it that would be
kind of spicy right no it's definitely
things would you send a dick pic Zack go
ahead it be honest I haven't done it go
ahead
I've only done it what are you worried
about always loosening it no stop go
ahead Zack tell the truth come on we're
all yes I've sent a dick pic yes and so
what was it that you seem conflicted
about doing so I wouldn't I wouldn't
send a dick pic - someone like I'm just
talking - yes consenting recipient yeah
I've only sent to my current girlfriend
okay good and was it at her request or
was that your prerogative you've got hot
and heavy okay it was reciprocated yeah
it was all yeah so ela if you were like
upstairs doing your thing the phone rang
your dings it's a dick pic from Ethan
would you feel flattered I think go
ahead
y'all let you answer I don't know I
think my first reaction would just be
like what the [ __ ] what well what am I
supposed to do with that because first
of all
first of all we're always together the
need to be transmitting pictures of my
penises is zero minimal second of all
the expectation for dick pics not there
third of all I am afraid of my dick
being on the Internet
so so for me we actually know but you
never know oh [ __ ] look at this you know
you don't know who's gonna you're
basically the minute I take a picture of
my dick
you better just expect that it's gonna
be on Twitter yes that's our set of mine
like yeah that's very opening yeah when
did I'm but besides that I am we feel
like we just didn't grow up having those
be part of our culture so I'm just
confused by this because you guys never
did dating jobs or anything no I've
never been on a date missed all that
yeah and now I'm not saying that there
I'm not like I'll say I'd send a dick
pic you know like does the girl return
something yes I think it depends on the
situation and yeah ideally the girl
returns something I think they did a
boob shot or vag shot because I mean how
did tell Marta to go I'm not gonna come
okay that's so Zach has been sexting god
bless you you think the the age of the
dick pic was created with these new apps
like tinder I think just smart abilities
send images like that okay
ian has been in love congratulations the
wild card she ruined the show but she
built your heart yes I look forward to
meeting her someday yeah sure you will
good me too I hope so and Dan talk to me
well what what's compan going on with
you not much I went traveling too I went
out to the great white north I was up in
Idaho over the break
why were you in Idaho that's where my
girl was from oh my god yeah and I'd
never been before and I gotta say
surprising amount of age three fans up
there I got you got recognizing I
in small-town Idaho it was it was it was
a trip yeah
so shout out to I think it was there was
a Jesse oh hey oh it was Dan it was it
another Dan Wow no I've never been there
but why do you love I know I like the
name yeah it's pretty epic it was
actually gorgeous it was snowing and
everything and you know all the pine
trees all white and everything I'm not
used to that being from you know that
was that was beautiful majestic yeah now
Dan you were there with the girlfriend
tell me about that how's that going it's
going good
yeah I met Matt her family and
everything Wow thank you good you play
good with the mom I think so I'm good
with you're good with mom after dinner
you help with the dishes and all that I
you know that's no I never we never had
we ate out the whole time oh yeah did
you bring [ __ ] over dinner when we ate
that's pretty good that's good you bring
flowers or like a housewarming gift you
know I didn't know just the dick-pic
good well Wow
love is in the air over the 2019 was it
was a potent year that's good I'm so
happy to hear that
everybody's got a smile on their face
everyone looks rejuvenated about you
what were you doing over break yeah oh
you never what did i do over break
nothing man
[Music]
our main goal yes we've been working
really hard later though we just wanna
we wanted to be with him and it was
super sweet that's great yeah it was
great we've took him to the zoo we went
out walking everywhere he's too young to
look at the animals but he was he's
captivated by the people and the kids
yeah it's nice just take him into public
places like that Theodore is growing up
he is close to crawling he's got two
little teeth coming in he's gonna be
eight months old on the 4th of February
every eight-month-old in this little guy
that's all we went vintage car shopping
right go as expected oh my god so I've
been hearing I didn't know if we were
gonna get into this so he lied hurt you
has been obsessed with vintage cars she
wants like a vintage car so we go to
this place they sell like beautiful
vintage there they look great they're in
great condition originally cold looking
Mercedes my vibes now I've been telling
Ellis since she brought this up to me
yeah I said yeah I support you if you
want this I'm not gonna tell you no I'm
just gonna give you a warning that these
old cars are pain in the ass they're
gonna always not work they're not gonna
run good and you're not gonna really
like driving it it's just gonna end up
sitting in our garage or driveway
spilling oil and so you know everybody
on Teddy fresh you look he was talking
about the vintage carbons car and it was
like funky thing trying to bring you
down either you go girl you do your
thing girl and then they go get in their
head you go don't listen to me all right
well I never had a problem with it
anyway so no but deep inside I know that
we are always on the same page so I knew
that Ethan is right like I kind of knew
it but I just I just like the look of
the car but it's not really that serious
look I agree the look is cool too yeah
but the thing is we go to the vintage
car these are these are the good ones
cuz you don't you don't want just a
piece-of-shit old car you want like
there's one that looks like it is
maintained right so the the cheapest one
here is 70,000 so right away on the
price I'm like either you can get like a
[ __ ] new badass car for that right so
already I'm like oh we were spending
$70,000 why don't we just get an awesome
new car yeah so that's the first thought
then she gets into this car the $70,000
car which was the cheapest one they have
there she gets in this car was that
white being our white Mercedes no it was
cream it was the one you wanted yeah and
so first of all the guy pulls it out and
he's turned it on he's getting into gear
he was gonna test-drive it and he's got
the clutch and he's like he's like
trying to get it here and he's like it's
a mercy it's a convertible top down it
takes two people screwdriver in the
drawer yeah crank it put in the window
is one of those so I'm like alright just
for commuting from the officer back so
EULA gets in the driver's seat now you
have to imagine the setting we're in a
garage it's a de facto shop yeah full of
incredible antique cars where ella is
getting into the cheapest one that cost
starts at seventy thousand yeah behind
ela is a antique Ferrari and rolls-royce
probably the two most expensive cars in
the garage nearly three hundred thousand
or more apiece beautiful and so yes
getting ready to go out on our test
drive and I'm not sure why but it wasn't
all there that was like this is very
normal here's drivers reverse go he
didn't show me anything
mmm-hmm do you drive manual like do you
know how to drive a stick shift I know
it wasn't it was just oh but the guy
couldn't get it in the drive right for
me I didn't have to do anything right
and I started like driving and it goes
backwards so ILA's going on and she's
not hitting brake she just looks at me
[Laughter]
[ __ ] but all I see is I'm standing there
in shock and she's just turned her
editors looking at me as the cars going
back towards the Ferrari and rolls-royce
was pretty fat and so I don't know
what's going on it was and and the guys
like he's like trying to laugh it out
and he was like panicking at the same
time and I was like what is I tried to
hit break in
was happening but then eventually he hit
they like he pulled the ebrake yeah and
then the car salesman is running after
them and I'm just sitting there like and
ILA's just staring at me you can imagine
just staring at me a shock and then
there was a guy in the car with her who
slammed on the ebrake thank God why
would they let you test drive the
transmissions all [ __ ] up in Drive and
it was rented oh my god why didn't the
pre get out of the car like all shaking
I just wanted to leave the roof and then
the guy who like take care of the car
yeah like their their handy mechanic guy
he was super nice and he came and he was
like he didn't want me to feel so bad
and he was like come on not all drive
and then we switch and I'll show you
first how I'm driving and they use and
then you drive and so I went with him
because I didn't want to also like say
no I was trying to be nice sure but I
was like horrified why I just wanted to
walk out what was with the brace so when
he took me on a drive he said just so
you know this happens all the time to me
too
and you would expect to like the drive
let's say is the drive use really like
down or something it's the opposite of
what it usually is so we said that
happens to me you put in Drive no the
guy thought he put it in Drive oh I
don't even do anything really God but
then how come the brake didn't work so
you've got a really slam it's like it
slow and it's like when you're used to
modern brake yeah like barely tapping on
yeah old cars aren't like that you gotta
like press you got a crazy oh yeah no
power steering either right yeah so you
test drove it and the end how did you
like it so then I drove it and it's like
the wheels kind of like takes a minute
the risk and I'm coming from driving our
like modern car it didn't feel that
great yeah and I was just wanting to go
out of there and we left and I was like
the dream is over what did you think
when you came back I just wanted through
your race
that whole day for my memory ela was
traumatized we got no car I always hit a
rolls-royce like what the [ __ ] and a
Ferrari right but I mean um I'm glad we
did it so you could get the bug out of
your system yeah so that's a you're not
all tall over
we already got she got a car so we were
like immediately we're over that a
different car a new car we got a new car
and convertible and it's awesome
congratulations thank you
way better so we say what it is you can
say I don't care I ended up getting a
Porsche is really nice no kids in this
car and it's our date car and we going
drives just the two of us it's really
fun that's pretty cool beautiful car
beautiful yeah and what else it's like
the same prices at all so that's that
story so ela came to her senses she
realized as always it was so good cuz we
came back from break and I opened up our
we have our like show dock or whatever
and like I just see a note in there and
like ela crashes classic car been
talking about the classic cars like it
was so scary
I thought I was like man I wonder if
they would have made you pay for it or
what like what would happen if you
actually no way how what if I can't
afford you I'm sure they have insurance
yeah probably yeah but I mean they they
screwed you but I think they would have
tried something like that those guys a
bunch of car salesmen you know sneaky
yeah they would have tried some anyway
there's that so Wow a lot has happened
there's a couple of videos I want to
watch before we get into the Year in
Review okay because I believe it's
important
stay up to date here we have Khalid
trying to crowd surf what I don't know
if this is older jumping usually when
it's 11 he comes into the crowd you know
people are get excited but you can hear
screams of no that's screwed those are
genuine scream he's done this before -
yeah yeah he's done this before is that
Khalid are you kidding
who else is that way oh I recognize that
pear-shaped body
yeah same frame I don't like it is
actually bigger than anyone in the
comments maybe clarify you attempted
murder that's what's ready they call
this you guys go all the way up and then
oh I have to like click you have to go
into the comments entire discussion okay
use reddit well you trying to get me to
watch other videos I don't see anyone
saying that it's not Khalid yeah
nobody's refuting it so it lets you go
with yes whatever well hold on what
other pear-shaped red both grant pant
wearing bearded we need to analyze I
mean I see that doesn't look like him
Khalid is we doesn't run like that like
I know is more like it
[Music]
younger any and Khalid is a little bit
big I don't think it kind of looks like
Fat Joe no he's been arraigned this may
be a coward hit John wow that was such a
fail maybe it's a stunt what a
regardless but are you guys really I
think you're right action you persuaded
yeah I'm not sure if that's him
can we pull up a dash a different hmm
usually read it cause that [ __ ] out like
immediately though let me affect that
nobody's refuting it let me do it sirs
is real interesting
that's not dj khaled I'm pretty sure
that's flyboy Tarantino wow I wonder if
Cal is not done with this public smear
job yeah that looks like the guy we just
saw but he's also had it yeah he's
tatted all over the best I didn't see
any time there was a no beard but he's
not wearing red pants mmm well he
probably hasn't rolled on her
no but if that was what are the replies
to that this guy doesn't have a single
tattoo on it what's that oh behind the
beard oh hold on the [ __ ] finger hold
on Sarah you're saying oh yeah neck
there's a tat yeah because I thought he
had like a long straggly beer yeah right
the tattoo matches he does have
something going on there yep people are
agreeing people are agreeing that it is
flyboy and this is the flyboy it's not
it's his signature move apparently oh my
god remind me not to go to his page
he said out of all the cities he toured
only to fail to catch him dude if I'm
him and I'm doing that I've got a plant
like Jax dudes in the floor on the same
sound you hear if somebody opens fire so
we need my justice bird DJ Khaled his
name cleared there is a DJ Khaled crowd
surfing video yeah I feel like he didn't
eat [ __ ] that hard DJ Khaled crowd yeah
this one he kind of fell he just kind of
thinks you wouldn't just come to Khaled
crowd surf ends up crushing fans I'll
watch the music or can you mute the
music cuz I don't want to get [ __ ]
this doesn't mean the mute it
[Music]
wait if I turn that down it doesn't
click on try the second one
well just just click am in no audio no
audio ok I gotta do it here's counties
get don't get Cal too high oh no they're
having too much fun it's not they push
him out there look at the [ __ ] back
yeah it's like quicksand they didn't
want him this was a big story this
twitch streamer begging for subs I bet
you guys you know people are saying
she's so disgusting she's begging for
subs is why everyone hates twitch
streamers go ahead watch it and some of
what you think okay how do you hold
speech about how I need subs and to get
this stream going if you like the
content blah blah blah how that results
in zero subs there are regulars here $5
a month
how are you have hours of time to watch
me and not Disney Plus for $5 a month
I don't know what do you do sir game
time to watch twitch and not $5 to
provide for the concept feel like she
just answered her own question
look what are you doing with your life
that you're sitting here watching for
hours and don't have $5 right well
they're mine what's your content those
are just complaining hmm no I don't I
think I read somewhere I'm not sure I
can't confirm that she doesn't political
commentaries I'm saying okay don't do
this left is best that would make sense
actually really heartbreaking because
it's like people just really have no
they've really don't respect me as a
content creator that is that is rough I
mean I didn't I don't think she's
representative twitch I think she's just
some I mean I don't know I've never even
seen this girl or this but yeah that's
um
the thing is I don't when people don't
really need to ask for subs people sub
if they find value yeah right but I love
how she's like I bagged you guys and not
one person subscribed it's like well
maybe your [ __ ] sucks
I don't know they say you know cheese
yeah well is it just water I guess left
is best no thank you
you don't think left his best to sir I
mean maybe I guess maybe err maybe it
says in the there was someone else under
the bus for publicity then promote
yourself ouch I just like both yell what
now we're just descending into why drama
anyway shout out to her yeah that's good
go if you like the content blah blah
blah for becoming the I'll look into
that cuz I'm curious if there's like
additional context to it or something
let's find the whole scooped yeah
let's dig in let's dig in a little bit
right into that did Philly do you
mention that have you guys been staying
up to date with Philippi he has been on
break - oh really
you came back yesterday with a quick
oh my god I you know every time Philly
let me pull up a shot every time Philly
D clickbait Smee I'm like what the [ __ ]
did I do
it's flattering I guess but I get in
distress yeah I think I must be one of
the most click baited faces on the
philip defranco show which they do take
as a compliment
here look I look at me I'm here what did
I do
oh the kpop March my lot
there's PewDiePie Oh Shane PewDiePie
Shane's gonna be hard to top thank my
girl wants to be number one yeah well
let's see I'm up here twice
I see Felix 3 this is just the last row
absolutely made an appearance so he's
Sonic even made an appearance huh he has
some pretty dedicated fans I bet you
somebody has a running tally of I would
love on the action edit so I don't feel
it's cool actually no I need to
oh here's PTC I need to get in and Shane
it's probably the number one right now
I'm actually seeing Felix a lot I want
to see someone he does david dobrik a
lot too I'm seeing him all over so
actually if anybody's listening has a
tally I would absolutely love to know
what that is I feel like I I got to be
in top 10 right Here I am again
top 10 can I have that title I remember
back top 20 when I first started
watching him and he was going by sex
again oh and the thumbnails were all
just like girls bikinis and stuff
remember that I've heard about that but
I wasn't watching that's for time
watching you too
this was like 2011 maybe how old were
you your aim again you guys I don't know
huh I'm seeing myself a lot here i am
again I'm just saying you are there a
lot I it's reasonable I might be in top
10 I think I'm top five
I'm not giving you some new top ten I'll
give you that just something somebody
does the podcasted h3h3 productions yes
please I need to know does the Israeli
live lag countess me what take a break
has it already been 30 minutes sure
having too much fun here back in the HD
podcast best show in the world
boys should get to it after the break so
then okay let's go to the break we'll be
back your review do not go away we're
just getting warmed up
ian is working on highlights as we were
never quit
what'll a head in the game alright you
go to a break we'll be right back guys
are you unhappy with that smile tired of
feeling self-conscious and photos why
not make this the year you straighten
your teeth with candid candy delivers
clear aligners directly to you and
stranger teeth for 65% less than braces
unlike braces candids clear liners are
comfortable removable and totally
invisible so you can transform your
smile without anyone noticing a thing
plus you never have to set foot in the
doctor's office or waiting room your
treatment is prescribed remotely by
licensed orthodontist and Candida livers
everything you need right to your door
unlike other companies canted only works
with orthodontist never general dentists
that means your treatment will be
designed by an expert in tooth movement
with 20 years of experience on average
looking ahead to wedding season or a
special event with candid the average
treatment length is just 6 months and
you'll start seeing results way before
then learn more about candids process
and get a complimentary 3d scan of your
teeth at a candid studio near you it's
simple freest way to get started so are
you ready to take the first steps toward
straighter teeth for a limited time you
can get started with $75 off by using
code h3a candid cocom /h 3 that's candid
cocom /h 3 use code h 3 for 75 $75
excuse me folks
$75 off candid code comm / h 3 code H 3
I'm H 3 you're watching H 3
quit makers of the quip electric
toothbrush wants you to know one single
discovery that matters most for your
dental care it is simply this that if
you have good brushing habits you're
good
that means brushing for two minutes
twice a day and flossing regularly no
matter what brand you use quit makes
that simple starting with an electric
toothbrush refillable floss and anti
cavity toothpaste quips electric
toothbrush has sensitive sonic
vibrations with a built-in timer and
30-second pulses to guide a full and
even clean the quip floss dispenser
comes with pre mark string to help you
use just enough plus clip delivers fresh
brush heads floss and toothpaste refills
to your door every three months with
free shipping so your routine is always
right join three million healthy mouths
and get equipped today starting at $25
and if you go to get equipped come slash
h3 right now you'll get your first
refill for free so that's your first
refill free at get quip calm slash h3
spelled g ET q UI p.com / h - Requip
it's the good habits company
welcome back you're the only one that's
back no one else is here I'm here dance
here I mean you know dance here my
chopped liver Dan's always here lack so
I was going to say I wanted to bring up
one more thing before we jumped into it
because we were goofing on not goofing
and really but the bathtub trough guy
look at this
that's the same dude that's the same all
right I'm so stoked for this guy what an
incredible journey well awesome isn't
this the best thing you've ever seen I
saw that and I cannot believe that for
him that was like impossible that must
have been so hard oh yeah but look how
happy he looks
yeah I mean it's got to feel amazing I
mean the guy could be probably got like
a new life no he's got a handsome dude
actually to a huge seriously I'm so I'm
just a see not a boy it's possible man
mmm I need to get inspired man I'm
getting too fat I can't fit into
clothing I've like this incredible
shorts collection I can't fit into the
shorts the feeding window I ain't doing
it
the feet of someone left the window open
there's a draught effect the fitting
window alone is just not enough you know
I got discouraged I didn't go vegetarian
pretty much I am actually pretty much
we're just not like super strict about
it so I sometimes do something but for
the most part yeah anyway let's move on
let's get to it shall we
okay anyway then I have I am fully
vegetarian still and I tried meat once
and I felt like you described like I was
so good what make the Jew eat your
brother got food for us would meet and I
couldn't know right you had the UM you
know that wasn't the best meat to be
honest but I'm just completely lying to
it yeah I mean I'm not surprised that me
it was pretty gross
I got to be dedicated to throw the
[ __ ] down what's your go-to cheap fast
food like if you were to drive through
somewhere and you just feel like
cheating
definitely a McMuffin yeah not really
I feel like the McMuffins are not that
bad no no I mean you could do worse not
and I would if healer wasn't with me if
it was up to me Zach I would go I'd be
happy with anything yeah the meat
Mountain bar now I wouldn't do that I
would probably get like a quarter
pounder with french fries or I would you
know so you go Mickey D's Carl's jr. do
you again and out I like in and out
anyway let's go let's look we have an
agenda right we have the best and the
worst I want to talk about how Hillary
slam Bernie let's save that for another
day yeah less mess what are you saying
ridiculousness Oh ridiculousness Oh what
about Wendy Williams ripping ass on TV
right that's New York yes Yas Queen so
good why save it for Friday so good well
now that brought it up I have brought it
bro this is the best Wendy Williams
ripped ass so hard so first of all as I
say everyone knows that she's like got
it done leg live be subtle or anything
she's having diarrhea or like because
well in that posture I generally don't
get so gassy unless there's like a storm
brewing she's working it Korky deport no
no no like a valve yeah yeah so like
she's trying to hold it in no she's
squeezing it out you sit flat yeah she's
trying to do it subtle yeah yeah because
when you're flat against the chair
you're gonna get that buddy I just yeah
it gets to a point where like you have
to let him I think she's trying to let
it out discreet yeah exactly so you
actually want to wash
clip okay you want to watch the clip of
so it's up on the screen I mean you
don't want to guess about what's in it
anymore there's 25 second clip you want
to actually watch it okay 27 years old
you're old enough to understand
political correctness and the times that
we live now yeah of course he probably
knows it's not right from a man to a
woman or a woman to a man but you can't
even do that locker room thing that cop
wasn't playing that I mean because she
was concentrating on the fart you can
tell her mind wasn't kelly there yeah
thank you right here we got it wait so
you're lucky you only got battery what
if he filed for sexual assault oh [ __ ] I
don't go back far enough I'm so sorry
everyone that cop wasn't playing that I
mean she stopped talking goes into the
nod mic pick that up yeah okay she must
have ripped fat ass yeah I think she
clearly thought that that it was
inaudible cuz she has a lab on her chest
but I think there's booms everywhere for
backup right yeah yeah for sure that
yeah I think she ripped an ass so hard
she didn't think that anyone could hear
it well I think she thought it would be
silent that's why she's yeah that's what
I'm saying that's what the pose is for
like with the what's the pause in the
pose there's no way to do that for the
whole time I think she was really like
trying Wendy Williams am i right wow you
are right you're exactly right Wendy
Williams she's like and there's no
hiding it because she likes stop
speaking she's gonna think about it but
what do you do if you need to rip ass on
TV you know what I mean and you're Wendy
Williams you've got you got hold it hold
on everybody I'm gonna flip back have
you farted on the HD podcast yeah and
Jacqueline heard it
you're the sound guy
you well I've never heard there was even
a reaction to it you don't really hear
it I don't laugh my [ __ ] like he does
the guest here though there aren't ways
around she could she could have faked a
cough or something
well that's the worst I don't think she
could like coordinate all that that's
not I'm a competitive art and talk at
the same time yeah really you can't do
it what you're saying that's like a
human limit you have to like pause
that's a human biological limit name
that seems like a challenge away because
you're pushing
oh I'm farting right now you can say
that next time you have to fart this
goes forever
I guarantee I can talk while I fart no
pauses it has to be like a full colic
talk I ask you you mean don't miss a
beat exactly no pauses not a second no
yeah and think you might be right when
did the way the Windy Williams child we
just we just had an on-air fart like
last month
oh the stall well our saw well yeah same
thing he did pause but we there was a
lot of it was the news reporter his over
yeah there was a there was a lot of
back-and-forth so what did what do we
find out was there it was there was a
lot of back-and-forth the the network
blamed a coffee mug dragging across the
ground he was a former employee of MSNBC
claimed that Chris Matthews the ho all
the time fart right and it was Chris
Matthews there was a partner on the
grassy knoll I feel like Chris Matthew
got
[Music]
Center much like what happened in DJ
Khaled earlier in the sub he did a
birdie through he did him dirty but all
right this is a good challenge yeah all
right I'll let you know and I when I've
got asked my fart my ass let's move it
on 2019 Year in Review great year
wonderful year so I will go first cuz
I'm already here
what you got now I'm gonna start with my
best okay now I'm gonna go all the way
back to Jack Black now this happened at
the very end of 2018 but I really don't
give a single hoots you're already
breaking the know this is the only one
this is the only one because it's right
on the cusp and we never talked about
this it was right on the cusp like I
mean like one day before okay so so stop
your whining don't you say the prayer
are you ready for it
are you kidding me tell me if I do this
correctly I this is the hard part
[Laughter]
[Music]
haha that's impressive
I was feeling fresh to have that talent
even pronounced a right like you would
in Israel he's a talent I just I'm still
marvelling at the fact that we had this
incredible talent Jack Black but loved
by the world in here doing doing a
prayers and song for us so that was
especially me he's actually one of my
favorite youtubers just kind of funny to
say yes he's great said December 7th
that wasn't what the Dan why are you
here you're supposed to support me and
it's not really the it's not the hospice
it was a spiritual core the cusp of the
spiritual December is the cup doesn't
like rules that's the only one that's
from 2000 ufff though to to transcend a
year so thank you in well somebody who
understands me
I was trending on a lot of like Jewish
pages on Twitter I didn't know that my
friends another favorite moment of mine
was the revelation that Sandra bollocks
bollocks what do you think let's say
bollocks bollocks bollocks bollocks
Sandra Bullock's injects Asian baby
foreskin her face yeah specifically
Asian baby foreskin you look like a burn
victim for a day but then it's it but
then it pushes what are you pushing into
the skin sera sera
what are you pushing into the skin well
you push in whatever the facialist would
like to insert into your pores but what
is it it is extraction from a piece of
skin free from a young person this the
why is it polite wait why was a clips of
me this is hard should be the source
hmm little late now yeah well it's the
best of the podcast yeah yeah that's
true so we need you there because
otherwise you're just gonna react to
gain okay so I'll just play the clip I
can't comment that's all it's like she
got caught red-handed
go ahead play this of the podcast and
not about reaction material that you
like what's the difference I liked this
clip that's a highlight what does it
matter everybody else is the same I
forgot that this happened so I am
appreciating yeah a reminder of the fact
that she injects baby foreskins and you
have any other critique at the top find
it deeply disturbing they did cuz I
missed it cuz ill was arguing with let
me go back and watch the clip of me
talking about it again but you don't
have to be disturbed
okay there you go why Korean I always
found that so so weird but yes they
import baby foreskin firm Korea and
inject it into their faces and you can
tell she knows how for weird and and uh
not cool it is even it's just strange
like kind of uncomfortable really
Illuminati yeah
well whatever the manicurist wants to
inject I wonder which Korea comes from
if it comes from North Korea that's
concerning interesting because you know
those babies are giving that for stuff
willingly I'm gonna say I'm like the
South Korean ones that are giving it
will well yeah because the I mean South
Korea is a you know democracy were so
the babies are electing to donate well
I'm saying I'm sure done Hugh Miller
it's done humanely with the parents
consent if it coming from North Korea
that's just a farm where they grow
babies and nip they're gonna guess it's
probably suck yeah you think in North
Korea it's like there's a forced
circumcision is that what you're saying
no I'm saying that in North Korea they
don't need your consent ones consent
divorce yeah they take the foreskin yeah
forcibly interesting very in a camp
Sandra Bullock okay mark McGrath cameo
for him okay this I know this was recent
acts I should give context mark McGrath
what became famous for making a cameo
breaking up with a girl's boyfriend and
it went viral everyone thought it was so
funny and outrageous that mark McGrath
is on cameo just delivering bad news I
mean yeah and the whole concept of cameo
I think is is funny to people as well
but I wanted to do something special for
ian's anniversary was your two year
anniversary is that right that's correct
and so we decided to commission for in a
little video of mark McGrath firing in
mmm-hmm so without further ado
Burt's but always in your hearts and
Ethan wants to let you know something
man these never get easier things are
getting tough around the office and
unfortunately at this time and I know
it's tough around the holidays
Ethan is gonna have to let you go
unfortunately money's tight right now
you know oil prices around the world are
going crazy and that being or telling me
business he's gonna have to let you go I
just can't afford to keep you around
anymore
you've been a great employee a great
friend and he hates to do this to you
during the holiday season and he thought
the best way to let you know that you're
fired was through me you know a lot of
cliches kind of come into mind right now
when something like this is happening to
you you know and the chips are down you
know when one door closes and finishes
the fun going it's not how many times
you fall down is how many times get back
up so I'm happy
Ethan and everybody we wish you the best
and you're more than capable family but
we're gonna let you go at this time I'll
be happy to mark your ground keep any a
wonderful employee there's you're the
best in the future well I thought he
said I was so in Christ and I will say
after we aired this on the podcast he
raised his price from 75 to 150 100 I
think it was from 100 to 115 and he's
like I'm the main like they really push
him now on the way well yeah he was
getting my copy plus a day [ __ ] me do
the math that's a lot of cheddar
did you see the deep the deep fake so I
made no oh yeah yeah let me let me pull
that up that was so uncanny dude well
that was the best mark the wrath of
McGrath how did you feel 125 oh maybe he
furloughed it feed sack
back how did you how did you feeling any
wha
do you watch this every day it's
actually my wake-up alarm gets me going
ah no it's he nailed it it's not us it's
used yeah it was on a really small
channel so yeah I just saw it on the
subreddit might not pop up on a search
unfortunately so that was definitely a
highlight for me yeah he really
delivered you know we we sent him the
money we sent him some guidelines really
minimal and he really took it around
with that and he was quick to and he
went for a while yeah he knows how to
how to deliver quality yeah I mean he's
got a reputation to uphold
he's a G he's a G so there you have it
mark McGrath next up the belt Delphine
saga for me stands out it nearly ruined
our marriage but to go and Zach's as
well you still watch her no you don't
watch her no you don't you don't ever
ever one you cancel premium that's false
oh you don't have premium San chap
anyone anymore anymore cuz you were
really into her for a minute okay video
of her spitting in the door she sent us
we I had wanted her to fart in a can it
sent it to me but she did the next best
thing she spit in a jar and as far as
I'm aware were the only ones that own
her spit she expressed me after my Scott
and it's still fermenting how much to
take a sip of that Dan Zak how much does
it take a sip of that 10 gram you might
die drink all of it 300 grand 10 grand
wouldn't cover your medical bills
not in that way but I was flattered that
that she thought of us here's the video
okay here we go I mean this is a video
this is it
you ready Allah yes she later admitted
to me cuz we cut week were notices
smelled like alcohol right find she
later admitted to me that she had poured
a little no idea she's ruling into a cop
and she said she wanted to get more
volume but I wonder if it's because she
was worried that we were 23 oh there's
that could be true but be honest who got
a semi job from this from this yeah from
her spitting it yes that doesn't do it
for you did you get a semi job no you
didn't rip up at all huh not even 1% I
don't believe I don't believe she
doesn't necessarily do it for me oh stop
you stop right in did you just chop up
at all just to semi would really corked
up joking I'm asking for real I'm not
trying to make jokes did you get I did
not from this it's it's kind of I get a
weird feeling in here yeah it's a
pulsing it's not attractive
did you you choked up you choked up ten
percent literally so you got like a
minuscule like just 10 percent she's
still totally am ia she gone I don't
know but I threw it all away you're over
it I don't know why because she was like
the center of attention everybody was
talking about about her she's like um
she's like Jerry Seinfeld she goes out
at the height of her glory mmm true well
if she had the whole meme about being
arrested mm-hmm right which was just
kind of a lot bad and that was [ __ ]
yeah I don't know if she's still at yeah
I feel like it was yeah oh yeah we
noticed here that um it mysteriously the
volume goes up geez it mysteriously
filled up about 50% the way through her
spitting marathon that must have been
when she poured in the alcohol mmm Wow
at this point she puts it back in her
mouth it's pretty incredible I mean she
did go all out I love him beyond you got
a hug from her yeah yeah that's right
that's part of the thing is that the the
authority continued to develop which is
what contributed to being so great for
example we decided to open it and
there's a good vacuum seal what it's
here listen like Wendy Williams wait are
we ready it's not look at how at least
one jar was way clearer than but at
least definitely getting [ __ ] well you
know what happened there's probably
probably is better hair there little air
pressure went along its spit out what
the bacteria was like no guy used for
yeah
sourdough right exactly that's right
gnarly
so there's like can you hear is that
okay well okay so hold off on that okay
yeah yeah but yeah this this is gnarly
good timestamp that man I am so blown
away it's just not what I expected and
operating YouTube for a youtuber bro
it's a one and a half hour time line
not even bored a minute if you press L
it goes is like a grown up girl because
I do think drinking alcohol no I called
no her bacteria what format smells like
Manischewitz yeah why do you take a step
we should going in no if Dan doesn't we
have to complete the circle opening it
up
okay wait put it up to the mic let's
hear if it makes the zone no interesting
I think that means there's nothing
active in there there's no this is how
the Walking Dead stated a deep me just
flew out so dance got it open he's
smelling like death oh my god
go ahead Ian your neck this is like The
Grudge how long did that been days this
was uploaded it was like in the summer I
didn't actually I never did I never
smelled it I don't like straight by the
way this has been marinating for seven
months don't spill that that'll burn
through this unbelieving if you can't it
smells kind of like like a like a old
bread yeah I got the yeast element there
falls red doesn't sound too bad
but like there's a thing in there
there's a demonic element yeah for sure
thoughts you still want to sip that for
10 G's
it's on the show it does smell like an
alcohol bread that's the way I can put
it I think of the fact that you're
smelling someone's spit whatever you're
smelling that was really like if you
smell if you smell a flower that had
that scent would you react the same way
you get a contact high from get a good
whiff well I got a good with just let it
marinate basking in I just want to get a
really good description so the thing
yeah it's like the alcohol is fermented
yeah you can really smell the yeast
bratty as foul drunk if you drunk that
well this is this alcohol she spit out
some I feel different to be on I think
it became less pungent by the time it
came around to me cuz smell was may
might have escaped yeah I think I think
you got the worst I might Asian 0vu ttle
well we did that and then vitally en ran
into her at the pornhub Awards writes
although you're the only one that
survived to to tell the story
uh-huh yeah that was a and I didn't
expect that to happen
um I didn't think she was gonna be there
she's so mysterious right so then when I
la I was like I gotta find her here and
yeah that was good work she was so
excited she knew who we were
and you were wearing the Hat yeah she
was she was so nice she's freaking out
I'm actually looking person I mean I she
looked like her
I mean I could see like where the like
where the wig she's dressed like on her
you know Grim Reaper or whatever yeah
but and she was with a guy right I
didn't see anyone who was she with
I didn't hear with anybody she's by
herself yeah it looked like it as far as
I saw I don't know anything else
I mean anything unusual not really I
told her what did she say to you I had
said I like pointed at the Hat and she
was like no way no way is that real and
I was like yes a replica she was like
where's Ethan where's the other yeah but
it was cool she talked to me for a while
well congratulations you got a hug
beautiful combination saga what kind of
hug was it yeah I'm curious are you what
are you kind of hug was like how long
did she ask you was it was there body
contact was it shoulders forward along
the Christian side hug yes what
percentage chubber you right now zero
well I'm trying to get up to ten but
you're holding Vito one of those since
when you do the power you do the pat you
got the Larry David Pat yeah did you
smell her I didn't go for the whiff but
you were right there did you not inhale
you went for the live I just with the
spit she smelled like rotten red in
Paris I think something happened between
them and he did not wanted to know no
well you didn't have a girlfriend then
what are you worried about he's all
groovy she just wanted to stay
mysterious so she I live with too much I
was trying to ask questions she wasn't
really we wanted to get a video she
didn't go up on stage either no it's no
interesting yeah well there you have it
Trish Delphine and next up for me Andrew
yang enters on the Gatsby fantastic
[Music]
[Laughter]
he's so careful we put on the lowest
speed
that's max feeding well after the
Bobbili incident especially when our
official he's a serious guy
ya know Andrew yeah I feel like that was
a milestone for our podcast having
Andrew yang a presidential candidate
here on the show was pretty well I me
that was uh let me tell you guys my dad
flipped out about that actually
alright why is he a young gang it's kind
of a hanging oh so he didn't expect that
yeah I haven't told him anything and I'd
literally got it I got a text from him
that said what the [ __ ] you got Andrew
yeah as long as Dan's dad is in I craved
your dad's approval more than my own
because you told me your dad is this is
a what's a fan of the rice gum video
that has those parents I think we all
determine it said are you [ __ ]
kidding me you guys got Andrew yang on
the show after the debate I'm impressed
nice there you go tell me if your dad
has any more compliments when I say okay
that helps busy see if or say anything
about me yeah did he say anything about
Dell Dell Delphine yeah he's he's real
indirection he had Dan I'm reporting in
all right let's keep blasting to take a
good long yeah Papa John gives us a
shout out that was like a lifetime I
love you have an award right this watch
this video look at this 2.4 million
viewers people are stoked for Papa hey
gang gang gang gang gang papa
well I have enough they don't pop back
this has been so surreal the Papa John
giving us a shout out well since we've
got in touch with Papa we've been trying
to book him for the show he got in touch
with me we talked on the phone for like
15 minutes Wow
it was a great chat how was good good
rapport really good Robi was nice good
banter super nice
I said Papa when you come on the show he
said to me Ethan when I say I'm gonna do
something I'm gonna do it and so we
booked we have a tentative date I will
say was the what do we say it's the
seventh I think right the day February
that so exactly that's the day of
reckoning that's on the calendar Papa's
gonna be in the house but he's got the
story he's got the goods he's got the
tea and he's coming to spill it he's
flying out just for our show
Wow and I could not be more excited Dan
that is so cool I couldn't believe it
because Ethan was getting a call from a
private number and we usually don't
answer anything was like oh yeah oh yeah
give it to me I guess you knew because I
like thing yeah and then he's like it's
papa now we had good banter he was me he
was pouring a lot of good yeah he said
yeah yeah he was slamming on he goes he
made some good jokes about shredder yeah
and all of his ex-wife being dogs or no
no but he made some funny jokes about
all of his ex-wives as well and then it
was very detailed like okay so when do
you want me to come out what time
where's the office like you could tell
he's a very he's a CEO yeah he's yeah
he's the franchisor not a franchisor is
a board I don't even know what to call
it is the beach that much like the very
official title used to see you and yet
you go pop Blake there's like new titles
oh okay well he's the board director of
the board yeah he's everything he's the
Alpha Omega and yes what else the alpha
beta and Omega the expression is just
Alpha and Omega oh he's got more Greek
Alpha and Omega of the pizza empire no
Papa dente
he'll stop in there but he's coming on
and I just can't believe it's so cool
I'm super excited pretty why I cannot
wait I also have an exciting
announcement on Tuesday PewDiePie is
gonna be joining us via satellite it's
not actually satellite but I like what
they say be a satellite so we have some
nice guests coming up I'm excited about
it's gonna be our first ever remote
guest throw shoe under the moon but I'm
saying that we just got 800 comments
yeah but anyway the worst I wanted to
show this one too before I pass it off
[Applause]
it's like a human experiment but anyway
the camera so close to their faces it's
just she's laughing so I know she's just
she's like what the hell any you know
keeps getting closer
[Applause]
[Music]
then when you think you can't get he
needs to step for man is good she really
has like perfect skin if you looked at
me that up close to you you'd be like oh
I got all these blackheads and [ __ ] like
probably owe somebody a coupon cameraman
yeah I'm sure it's so talk about perfect
skin look at this that movie yeah that
was a great movie but do you hate people
that loved it I do not almost single
blackhead he's almost six he doesn't
have a single black Etica smoothest skin
is how was that possible
he's gone almost sixty anyway I'm gonna
worst worst oh the Thanksgiving make him
laugh everybody was clowning on me for
ruining the episode because if people
didn't laugh
then I replayed it about your science
got very upset that you were not abiding
by your own rules and rules today
doesn't like to think inside a box yeah
alright thank you Zack that's
complimentary mmm-hmm well people didn't
like that I was bragging about I didn't
think I was gonna lose once and then I
was laughing at everything
hey so I got I got some shredded on the
accelerator
[Laughter]
yeah I'm not good and I ruined it and
everybody was fun well that was my worst
moment okay one of the other worst
moments for me was everybody accusing me
of cheating it's because I dared to say
that it's okay to look at someone's
Instagram profile out of curiosity we
didn't say you're cheating
it's infidelity but everyone in the car
yeah I was about to say we all got
trashed yeah well they took your side in
the moment I felt attacked but justice
prevailed and you all first of all do
you hope for a recap I was saying that
some girl sent a love note to end
to Dan sorry hmm and I looked at her
Instagram profile because she provided
it out of curiosity yes and then said
well I didn't look and then I said it
makes sense cuz he has a girlfriend so
he didn't look I said both that you
don't know everything started I said
[ __ ] you didn't look and you go whoa
and then you all go oh well look what
you would look and I was like yeah
somebody sent me I would look at of
curiosity and then all of a sudden all
you coward
with girlfriends yes coward said I would
never look what I think and I think that
it's wrong to look know it and is more
specific than that you were accusing me
of being a liar saying in this instance
I didn't look and I don't think you're
lying still didn't add a principal after
all I was like now I'm definitely not
honestly stick by your gun 150%
you can't go more than two percent then
how'd you sense the most you could give
by definition of the phrase you can't go
more than two percent what what what is
the limit on
100 percenter is max that's it that's
all you can get there could be 200% know
200% means more than the hundred that's
double 100%
how can you give 200% of your effort you
only have a hundred percent to give by
definition of a hundred percent that's
the max everything 100% okay he's right
thank you
I think people should allow a thousand
percent because it's clearly exaggerated
for slang no a thousand so what like a
thousand percent that's cool
so you agree a thousand percent take a
thousand might be a little too high yeah
I think the cutoff is a hundred fifty
well that's outrageous cuz then I just
think you're lying
what York overcompensated just laying
those like a real to you even after the
back left all agree yeah you all still
hold firm see not to not to litigate the
past again not to pull a Hillary Clinton
on you but by there was a lot of talk to
each other in that conversation too I
remember because again I was mostly
getting fixated on the fact that you
were accusing me of lying in that
particular instance which I absolutely
was not I was I was just finished
because then ela
was interpreting that as you saying it
would be okay it's I said yeah would be
lemon right I didn't like that and I see
but then the comments I'm willing to see
it both ways I think those good people
on both sides know there's good people
on both sides
no okay very diplomatic I just of what
the thing is I think you guys are full
of [ __ ] okay if you were single would
your answers possibly be different yeah
yeah the point no no if you were single
would you say it's okay to look yeah oh
it's theoretically if you you're saying
if we were
the argument they were single and you
says if I was in a relationship it would
be because the girl is watching and
she's gentle no wait I'm very confused
by ways you know making sense but of
course they would say no no I don't know
maybe they'd be honest with me rephrase
what if you were single you force us to
be honest on this show all the time yeah
and you guys still lie to me no if you
were single Zack and I asked you
hypothetically yeah if you are in a
relationship and a and you just looked
out of curiosity because the situations
like this you are behind the podcast @hh
reproductions if somebody said hey Zack
you're cute
here's my Instagram profile you will
click it out of curiosity no that's not
do it again that was the whole
conversation even if it came through at
the podcast at a few productions email
if I was single
like no girlfriend in the equation but
I'm in a loving relationship that's got
nothing to do with me I don't want to
look at other girls though that's resent
that and I'm not okay still give someone
back here
well apparently yeah everybody back well
I do back you up I just don't want to
have this argument mine too and I'm
secure enough in my relationship to
admit that and the audience a great idea
yeah Ethan I love you and I agree with
everything you say Wow that was your
worst moment after all so and so and
then finally the worst for me or the
most shocking maybe was um this really
iconic clip of turn away Dan eating the
giant lobster claw you know
what her mukbang turned on my my Siri
you know as I was pulling this clip I
saw that eating with Q and we loved the
two big MOOC bang channels are having a
beef having it really oh why are we
tracking there they were yeah we should
have a good drama yes absolutely
you won't forget I'll make a note right
now apparently some some of their text
messages between them got leaked and
they're like really trashing each other
they got tea oh yeah ago I think it's
more wheat they have beef or they're
eating beef so they should have a baby
ba I've never seen them eat beef only
seafood I don't know why they're
obsessed with seafood
we're dango phone call maybe hello we're
doing a show who just walking out maybe
he just received an Instagram profile I
wouldn't be surprised
does he have the [ __ ] that weird is
Sarah can you hear me we're saying what
is Dan doing
he ran out the door what what wait do
you really think he has the shit's wide
we know he was looking at his phone yes
me oh did something happen the way it
just emergency up and for Dan's life I
have to really I don't know I hope today
are you so I'll go and see what's up
wait you have to play really had a break
why don't you go on the break
I go on the break of a gradual blending
I gotta go again I've been chugging the
water probably you got you got a
moderate what would your honey bear
don't drink so much because I want to
drink but then it's a bounce
yeah all right get the hell out of here
go to the bathroom well you'll it's your
turn it's my turn but how you gonna
present these to a hooligans gun what
you say it's yeah let's just switch
seats I get some chitchat hello I feel
like the third wheel
I cannot believe in you my boy who
at all time I back you up on everyone
would leave me in the trenches on this
one how could you not click the link it
doesn't matter like ela okay eels my
soulmate I would click the link it's got
nothing to do and it's fine it's not
like I wasn't actually accusing you of
anything I just thought I know you were
a CLE I had a problem with the issue but
I'm willing to see it both ways there is
what happened are you serious yeah you
didn't say anything you just decked out
how its printed we were like well yeah
[ __ ] no I just had to pee so then just
gave you a soundbite all right we'll go
ahead them because Ian took the
invitation now should we wait for Ian we
don't need to wait for you and he's
gonna talk he just sits there quietly
okay one of my best moments
[Music]
that's one but also I was at home and
you did this episode that's why you just
got to give it more custom gussto there
me too this happen this is so sweet
it's like surreal I can't even believe
this happened only seven months ago
yellow those are tears of joy and the
expression on her face with the baby
there I mean it's just it's like all
inspiring you know he's got a little
beanie on he's really grown and
something this one he really does
resemble that already looks different
door he looks more which is funny
because when you look at him you have no
idea what it looks like but now you can
see it yeah sweetheart man says it all
for me yeah this is like I haven't
looked at this such a powerful photo man
god this was like the day after to write
inside one word
yeah that you did this it was no I don't
think I think we were in the hospital
for two days so it was like three or
four-day right this is the one I
remember because you would like barely
slept how beautiful you Liz oh this is
directly after giving birth
Wow cute so maybe in 2020 we'll be
having another one mm-hmm
something do what is it surreal you guys
have a child yes I forget sometimes
no no but like having like a moment it
was just like all right like where it
just hits you that you have this being
like right where's that kid but we have
moments where we're like who is he like
because he's already a guy who there is
only so much influence we're gonna have
one him but he's already whoever it was
this night just a few nights ago where
he woke up in the middle of the night to
eat and I was and after he was done
eating he was just sitting there like in
my lap like this just staring at me in
the dark and his face he looked like
such a little kid and he was staring at
me for like 20 minutes not blinking and
I was looking at him you're just staring
at each other for like 20 minutes in the
dark so surreal next up is Devan Affleck
it's too sad right now give some context
here so it was a random TV something I
don't know on YouTube it just popped up
and you know you were like you know this
is a real tattoo and I was like no way
that's a real tattoo and I was just like
I could not believe believe well then
the great part of the story is that he
lied he said at first it was for a movie
right about
right and so it kicked off a whole
competition of what's a worse tattoo how
do you try and lie about something like
that
that makes it so much better yeah thing
interesting happened ela said she saw a
picture of Ben Affleck's back tattoo I
was like man you guys he is crazy back
tattoo of I guess it's like a Phoenix
I don't really know but it's huge of
course it's whole freaking back it's
super colorful it's it's well done for
what it is but it's like you just you
would never expect it so I'm shocked
like a Yakuza I think this is the worst
tattoo I've ever she said really minute
well she said Ethan I think this may be
the worst tattoo I've ever seen
now I feel like that can't be true can
it why do you hate it so much it's just
awful I like the character like way is
that the color is Phoenix the fact that
it's all over his back right it's the
size that bothers you it's the color
it's the it's just wait to see it it's
I'm not still convinced like this is the
worst do we ever the cow Hall on that
now that was close but it was the the
guy with the one on these yeah oh yeah
yeah you scroll down a little bit yeah
that finds the worst tattoo ever
that one's worse ela yeah I went to
prison for like weird sex right I don't
think that he did I think his dad did I
was dead okay good mmm they were both
participating in the same okay fantastic
mmm what'd I do for me I didn't have the
same yes the best bonding what's the
point being famous if not that what's
the point of being a dad if someone
famous
oh hey dad wasn't famous on his own no I
could see my dad doing that if I was if
I was sleazy as him
and my dad was single I mean I could see
it you may have rated it higher but I
don't know you gave a lot of weight in
your rating system to Ben Affleck
celebrity yeah I never had the same
reaction to hood that you did I mean I
see it as corny but the worst tattoo
ever I mean I don't know cuz it's still
technically I thought that was a lot too
but really she pleaded her case yes she
didn't buy well yeah
so all right well congratulations too
bad well she got okay another obvious
one is when I got I can't forget you're
a citizen you're American
that's so cool yesterday he'll just
became an American citizen
[Music]
[Laughter]
what is that banana he look closer to
the mic sir said thank you scarf
goodness eel are you here probably the
best poster smash was epic Zell I
remember after that then you went out
and then smashed the boxes oh yeah I had
to go print that and that was so
stressful
nobody confronted you right no I printed
the ELA one in the the printer broke and
so a guy had to come fix it and he was
kind of like alright you got everything
I'm like yeah go away this is like so
American you could print this a huge
print picture of bin Laden and no one
was saying it no like in Israel you
would get so many questions you can't
print a picture bin Laden in Israel not
just that anything that's a little weird
you know people will be in your face
about it what are you doing why I see
people whatever I was there actually
that happened to me a few times
Oh people where did you up yeah for what
just random stuff I remember I remember
once I was I was just taking pictures
because you know I was like a tourist
and I got approached by a couple
security people because there was like a
school nearby and they just saw me
taking photos in the vicinity of the
school you know that means what you that
they thought you looked like a pedo I
think it was more of like a terrorist
kind of thing yeah at the time I did
actually oh yeah I could see it no I
could see what the beard people aren't
you heart yeah like some oh yeah like
how they interrogate you out there out
there yeah that happened to me to it
when I got there they pulled me aside
yeah they're here oh no whatever did you
go on birthright no I went to visit
family uncle lives there my grandfather
at the time
so that um Gatsby entrance is leading me
actually to back in time the first time
we got the Gatsby mm-hmm and that was my
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
wallet I don't even have I guess that
says something about me right there this
thing shreds so hard cuz everybody that
doors pretty brave
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
I so feel shame we haven't explored that
concept in a h3 video mm-hmm I wanted me
I want to drive it like you're just
around I know like just yeah didn't we
have the idea to like get it in the road
and get someone behind me to film me
could still do that a Hail Mary no yeah
so my one of my worst moments was all
the eating segments okay um I
specifically chose one Ethan the beast
[Laughter]
sandwich and someone said that was the
first time they saw someone deep throat
[Laughter]
hmm the jiggler did not elicit that kind
of reaction from that was better that is
viscera and I say immediately Popeyes is
about I never expected that sandwiches
so Bob no chick-fil-a it looks okay baby
you had in mind
oh wait no you eat right oh it's like I
mean I won't go oh and it's legit spicy
too just because of the line that she
somehow would drive to drool for it but
this whole waiting any one more bite
okay this is my life okay
that crazy yeah we had a real on-camera
fight well I don't know those let out
today RVs meat market which was the
thing which made me go vegetarian so we
knew do another food review guys so on
the front on the front line was from
like a crumpled paper bag more diarrhea
brown pastrami
Yeah right chicken are you gonna try
let's see what no no it is very good yes
it wasn't really I was pretty down with
it it's not something like you can't
order that twice though once in a while
yeah it's one time you're done
there was only one Arby's in all of Los
Angeles that sold it to we had the right
amount
my last worst moment is one raesha
Trisha Paytas and then it's fast revenge
I think human yeah but on a scale of
attraction
no you don't your hundred my type I
can't say I'm front I know you're my
immediate reaction yeah I'm confused by
that I've never been rated ten yella
yeah what would you rate them but you
wanted me to know it's been yeah I think
would you would you that was pretty fun
if your advice and moved on would you
make a move on me yes well and let's
bear in mind that in the same episode
she said that she's both trans and a
lesbian and she's kind of forgotten
about that whole thing so so are you
saying she doesn't think I'm a ten cuz I
take that's the only thing I have don't
think that I won't apologize let me have
that that's it those are my moments next
dan the man all right well bless through
this how long we've been going Sarah
gonna be a long one just out of
curiosity minutes that's right not good
not too bad I'm not trying to wrap it up
just
here's okay so you're my FirstBest and
really after most of the credit goes to
Ethan despite how he portrays it in this
clip used to pray this is your bad not
your worst I mean it's funny yeah what's
funny birth of a beautiful samba
yeah yeah that's true fantastic was so
good to make it clear you were like
spamming me we have a discord that we
use because recently deceased father
so no didn't want to do it so I was like
say it's a by you I I did it and it was
good then of course and I mean this is
beyond best of 2019 this is Jeff what
that music no it's you recognize him
yeah yeah we found this on and the
YouTube with the regular but I mean this
is the
we go look at this by the way at the
time it only had seven thousand how many
oh girl look at Ison the regular you got
it yeah
the regular huh get 40 Wow look at that
look what we did
I'm 7,000 why this this is this deserves
alike and give that a like right now but
yeah just the regular in general I mean
this is the whole the whole saga is
really the best for me you kidding me I
want the regular
Megillah
maybe she might not not the regular
smuggler were you kidding I think the
jacket comes off so iconic
I think they were nominated for Best
ensemble at the streaming really really
I think they won no.1 is awful I'm not
kidding
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
I mean that could explain that to
yourself when we initially stumble upon
this which amazed I mean did somebody
send it to us or did we just on that
edit page okay and immediately we were
both like this is the best thing I was
like crying laughing it had it's like oh
good like below 10,000 views for like
months before we you know gave it the
bomb deserve because now waiting we
weren't sure if we're gonna make a video
about it we were oh we kind of kept in
yep and wow he's just like this his
whole being is the wrong wrong I watch
every day yeah morning ritual yeah yeah
he's still tweets almost every day the
whole ritual I think this might be wave
of the decade we can't really say
regular anymore oh yes oh yeah I find
myself saying the SH Magilla say that
too like the Teddy French theme and I
forget yeah alright another fantastic
moment and maybe my favorite happened at
all last year was the Oliver tree
episode well and the the Ethan versus
all vaping joke you said that is how
many watts six six million you want to
see one more yes I feel like that was
entry level I'm warming
not bad okay that was pretty dope yeah
give it a little smoky enough all right
let's see what you got here oh boy we
get a drumroll
hey I didn't get a drumroll no no don't
give him a drumroll the king
seriously though can we get the drumroll
and he's trying not to laugh I think can
I get a countdown all right here we go
cricket sounds off to Frank get my
drumroll yeah
dad or Zach this this shows not as well
as I thought
[Music]
he's hitting it hard he's sucking it in
I'm scared I'm shaking this is a hard
[Music]
[Laughter]
charge this thing no that looks usually
it's like that you were trying to humor
him a little bit yeah there was good
rapport he's good but as an addendum to
that although because that not to toot
my own horn but we were having some
technical difficulties sorry sir all
over trees and then my last my last
greatest the Ethan Bradberry regular
thing made me laugh really hard but
nothing none laughing as hard you
already know it is that's got to be a
tough one that [ __ ] is so down the
Treader eats the same way pauses while
is eating
man this gets so bad entertainers you
don't blink
think about that why you choose
[Music]
something that almost feels like
pornographic about yeah there's someone
jerking off to this no no no he can do
that that's insane
that's so much so dead really
it's a beet red so insane
oh god yeah that was that fleeing great
mom I remember my stomach hurt me yeah
and then and the worst part one of my
worst was the special cake that we made
for Zach instead of frosting mayonnaise
means masterpiece
answer me now Gant has a managed phobia
yeah I mean after this I do if you
didn't before you definitely do know I
didn't think it was that bad I was so
close to throwing up the smell was what
[Laughter]
it was like so wait just looking at it
was like well yeah and it was just
oozing it wasn't really like frosting
falls in shape yeah exactly there's a
runny we like melted I remember this
lurks in here I don't want to show you
taking a bite I never took a bite of
that he did it but you did eventually
taste mayonnaise with the pie and all
that good which was bad but the pump
think about what the pumpkin pie wasn't
it was taller the smell of the cake
oversaw a lot of mayonnaise on that cake
yeah no it was did you get disgusted
yeah I mean I was like elbow deep in
mayonnaise but I would bring it past Dan
domestic how's this looking so there's
sort of a little compilation I have
going on here so this is a compilation
of me [ __ ] up the doorway in walls
which dam was the one who had to thanks
so this was the first the the first day
and you know this was one of your best
because I'm responsible for fixing it
you know the traffic if we take a Disney
trip a company event again this year we
should bring the Gatsby I knocked the
door off the hinges and then I can't
blame you for this podcast Bobby Lee we
could have seen it coming before there's
already chaos IMAX I'm pretty much not
coming because wait I just realized
there's a Getty image stamp on the
poster we can do anything and it's not
really a joke because Dan was just like
oh yeah I could probably you can see it
just take a chunk that was the day after
I fix and you wanted I remember one that
you wanted it fully closed and to just
slam it like we still need to do that be
amazing yeah it'd be amazing it's art I
mean look at the door frame it's art
like Bobby really [ __ ] it up I think
there's actually like structural damage
to the frame yet I just want to hit the
door I don't think I'll hurt yeah well
you're the neighborhood's act nobody's
right
it would be awesome I'm like cool we
don't want to see that hello you got
we're here to entertain the beat ball
okay Zach is right it would be awesome
right hell yeah
yes all right cue Zach's got your back
and that's it
that wood that was get in there Zach
Zach Zach Zach Zach Zach Zach Zach yeah
okay I was just doing that to avoid
there got dead air already so I wanted
to go through and talk about from this
past year the most iconic soundbites
angle I've become the sound by God like
forth you're way over there what's going
on just yeah just bring it over there
man dope don't rip it like hesitate okay
so mobility Mary of course corners first
time we watch this Dylan with that the
debut Kern
I remember this one oh my god I'm on the
edge of my seat that's such a great
sound bite well there's no like she's
not doesn't have like she's the best
where's mobility marry ah we need to go
on a quest to find her but she lives in
LA we half duel and this year 2020 make
it our mission to find mobility marry
and get her on the show she's in LA you
didn't really want to do that yes
you got a scooter off you have an oh I
might have an in what is the probability
that I don't want to reveal too much on
me okay yes I want to make that happen
that's a big goal you have in here dan
says he has n I'll tell you after the
show
well we need to get a skirt lead yeah I
got a scutella we okay good I know a guy
who knows a guy who cut off the exchange
insurance okay let's see what you got
there you go just saw the birth of the
DD mega doodoo somebody
[Music]
so crazy complete that fallen officer
what way to honor her by calling our DD
mega dude yeah and then we got the human
version of Kermit the Frog see this one
I love and I feel like people haven't
responded very also Lance sounds like
Kermit the Frog and I just love you guys
I mean she's wearing a gold in this
video he starts talking immediately
after that and sounds nothing like
fantastic moment and then we have
another great song by mr. littles and is
my is fantastic lolz apparently this guy
from the highlight called
Roseanne has a low IQ stirred a little
controversy so this guy was just like
hey dude you know [ __ ] you or whatever
for saying that [ __ ] about my boy to my
bike back so this is what he thinks
there's always street cred
who says get out get out of how did he
never get busted for that he's so trashy
geek his girlfriend's driving [ __ ]
he's like flaunting a [ __ ] gun how is
he not but what is he asking him to get
out of get out get out
shoo there's a strangest way to speak
right get out he thinks he's like tough
but no it depends on the context and
they're in there outside yeah they're
outside so get out I guess would be to
get in Wow who Jerry Seinfeld over here
get out yeah get in and to round up are
you guys watching curb did you like it
wasn't it just absolutely amazing I have
a feeling that anything wasn't like even
well I got more into it loving it the
last the last half I liked the first
half I felt like I don't like when Larry
is doing things that are so ridiculous
okay
like when you just grab the selfie stick
and broke it over his knee isn't it what
you all want to do you know what I mean
but it wasn't there Larry David wasn't
always like that it was he was character
was realistic and now I feel like he's
become such a caricature but it's not
like he's not like a real person anymore
he's just like mr. Magoo
he's a my kind of did I I couldn't watch
last season I felt like it like it caved
in on itself to elevated his gift there
was two being picked a lot right big
cartoon yeah the fossil ah you didn't
like the photo yeah the whole the whole
last I don't know you like the pickles
it felt like our pickles him doing what
we think Larry David should be doing it
so much
I don't know yeah I agree but that being
said I did enjoy it I I like the whole
premise that they're that they're
building yeah I thought it was one of
the best episodes of care but I've ever
seen I'll check it out really yeah I
thought it was just the whole episode
the timing of it was just I mean are
they usually an hour long yeah cuz I was
like yeah it's a lot of content what do
you guys laughing about just
everything's a disease is the greatest
yeah I like gee I don't you know a lot
of [ __ ] knows X the best I like to
remain positive I know you and I love
you for it
I'll take it as a compliment opposed
that Larry David will put out right now
would you David ela he's too old he's
like I feel like he would [ __ ] Larry
David but age aside I do think that he
looks good for his age Wow
it'll ex the way he dresses like 40
years he actually look worse because his
hair was all crazy right Larry David's
the only man who threatens my marriage
no but like in his prime but in his
prime he wasn't as attractive no he
looks better now why is he too old love
knows known his own age okay moving on
so Ian this one's about you okay this is
for it to close up my best what this
good I thought we could talk about the
origin of probably the most played
soundbite that I play yeah
the bane of aunt's existence kind of
like the beginning of all sound bites on
this body yeah the genesis how you talk
to me I'm doing a piece
Zach what about your good and at first
like that was the first time right yeah
that was the first time though it was
March 1st 2019
oh we were like oh yeah well and then it
was off because we like why yeah but it
just kind of worked out I won that
whenever I was drinking that water that
day I had no idea one of the NA meetings
would never be the same that's right
and for my worst I mean can't
Cheers much worse than there we go
Origen yes
I mean I haven't watched this back so
three bike I mean this is pretty and
those bikes are so big into a corner yes
big game I think no thank you
yeah I'm not trying to take anything
away from your treatment thank you wait
who someone else came in and hit the
mayonnaise and was saying they did
better than that you did great yeah that
was I know you're all you still have
like 3/4 left but not not I don't want
it to slow it down too much also don't
you get what you get 1/5 bites once it I
was sitting right next to you and I you
felt like I couldn't really those you
amazing that I'm I'm impressed I don't
know if we can show which this did end
in disaster
yes I we ended the show I was on my way
home I felt like this gurgling in my
spine my [ __ ] gut my girlfriend was
coming over and I'm like I need to go to
the bathroom I go in the bathroom and I
just throw up straight mayonnaise Oh
whose strain was wife like male and that
the taste was made causing me to puke
even more vicious cycle so you probably
picked out a lot yeah and you puked in
the toilet yeah and what it looked like
wow it was just it looked like the spit
to tell you the truth it was like the
face and I hadn't eaten anything like
all day and are you are you off man why
do we even do that it was he thought he
could do it right so we worried
something right okay now are you off
mayonnaise and horsey sauce or has not
fazed you
I've stopped eating Arby's can't do our
Ruiz anymore well why are you eating
Arby's now regularly stole our bees like
or deal with the meat Mountain [ __ ] but
the mayor is fine Mayo is fine but not
you know spoonfuls well yeah that's very
understand about potato salad okay
there's like two things I won't eat
three things tell us
cream cheese what that's weird tomatoes
that's more cottage cheese what Oh in
Greek yogurt for so we're gonna blend
all those together
oh great when I'm with you on that
tomato
oh it's disguise will you eat it on a
sandwich cooked like rosetta Lake with
mozzarella
salsa it's also so close again brush to
my cottage cheese water Greek yogurt
okay so we're gonna blend all the for
those I would eat that have you had good
cottage and you still don't like it I
hate it I hate I would if I blended
those and put it on toast I'd be a great
meal oh let's see smoothie how much to
drink good yeah sounds good how they
drink the spit tell you the truth are
you [ __ ] I cannot swim smell so Greek
yogurt to the ultimate I like super my
yeah that like you're running fine right
Oh disgusting I hate it but no my mom
used to buy him and I would throw him
over like my backyard
cuz I couldn't like yeah like she is it
the fact that the neighbor's yard
yeah there's living bacteria and it just
the smell it smells like a goat's ass
hole like okay good to know good to know
I hate cream cheese everybody what about
cheese days I like cheese good yeah
there's cream cheese
I know layer looks like but I'll eat
I'll eat I'll eat locks you're writing
and I think we should all like put on
party hats and eat it on toast and like
just be really enjoying it and then
Zacks like puking I mean that's blended
together yeah like a liquidy we drink no
it would be like a spread I think it
would be pretty thick no I feel like the
Greek yogurt I can't shake it depends
how much you put in I guess so a shake
out I think we should all do it and see
how well we fare I think so too
I think that would be the funniest cuz
Zacks just gonna be dying and we're all
gonna be enjoying ourselves
you wait you would try that you would
try that yeah up for it I mean I was
great I don't agree that sounds great
but it doesn't sound bad stuff you like
cottage cheese yeah okay so you like
cream cheese yes you like Greek yogurt
yes yeah that's fine and tomato I can
tolerate say you go me none of it sounds
awful
okay good we got the thank you for
sharing sounds like my
but do you have any have Mayo's as your
food foe but you have any other like a
big one really yeah
I don't like blue cheese dressing like a
blue cheese okay it's disgusting there's
am you could see mold on I wonder who
eats this it's like it's literally
rotting trash so good well that's what
cream cheese I'm just weird like that
cheese is like the best food a bad one
shovel it in my mouth bro could you eat
it on the spoonful yes I do it's all
good bro a spoonful of cream cheese yes
yeah I mean I guess yeah it's pretty no
problem would you if I already phobia
not really just whatever I like
basically if a man if you give me like
this shake that we're talking about or a
pizza I might go for the shake this
cottage yeah yeah she [ __ ] hates you
just say to me I don't hate you I just I
don't I might flip out don't you find it
strange that somebody could even say
don't care about pizza that much
actually my girlfriend told me she
doesn't like pizza either that's sick
that's a mental that's a red flats on a
marriage illness that's on American yeah
I just find it so laylee yeah it's such
a blanket there's the variety of pizza
you can go love it so say I don't like
most of it because most of it is like
you wanted a house it's really good
isn't there there's one right down the
street that's fantastic so we eating
that for dinner night yes or no is the
window open yeah make sure it's no I
love cream cheese I love cottage cheese
yeah me too sounds great yeah I agree if
I came in here with like two big things
of cream cheese and a spoon
could you eat the whole yeah I could
yeah that's cheese I could eat the whole
thing
well if I couldn't it's just because
it's not from being grossed out it's
just a lot yeah
I could easily eat a whole thing cream
cheese or cottage cheese in fact I found
a really good cause she you know in
Israel they make the best cottage cheese
it has a lot of fat so it's a lot
thicker and we found one that's that's
actually close to what they sell in
Israel that's so fantastic it's so
delicious
I'm sure you'll hate it probably because
you don't even like cream cheese but
I'll bring that in it's really good
oh okay I'll try it do I have a food
wheat neck weakness I think just like
shellfish is my food weak but it doesn't
it's not gonna make me like I yeah I
just think it's gross like shellfish
it's just disgust or shrimp lobster
although it is like the most heinous
thing to eat it's like a livers the
worst chopped liver chop or no no no
chopped liver is not as bad is like a
straight-up grilled liver no that's
disgusting that's like more like a heart
any of the organs the heart the lungs
people eat all this [ __ ]
I'm not down yeah mmm but I don't think
I'm think that's unusual
here in America anyway we like to just
we like to just put that in a hotdog or
throw it out you sell it to Mexico I
think it's great you should eat the
whole animal it's [ __ ] up that I am so
repulsed by that but I'll eat the end
the threatened muscle you know bad I
mean that's just as gross and one of the
main dishes is like liver over mashed
potatoes kind of good
your sister goes so beast mode she loves
like chicken hearts she'll go to
restaurant order chicken hearts and she
just is like be smoting yeah they make
it had like grill like kebab place yeah
and she's just eating hearts and livers
and I'm and I'm like this is I was like
this is too much yeah she's a gnarly
dude what about pigs feet would you guys
no no Bobby no dude hell oh yeah I know
but I want to eat pigs feet that's hard
do you guys eat pork I guess eat pork
but I'm not it's not my go to me bye
means you know what else we got here
oh that's it are you do your worst yeah
all right thank you that in Zack Zack
and then push push it in let's go I wait
you think pizza tonight
ela you guys don't care just so you one
thing that I'm like hating you
good you promotional prisoner whatever
it takes to get pizza
alright so oh yeah for this one this was
like the hardest I'd ever seen you laugh
as up to this point working here so yeah
iconic video man it's amazing his head
shoots up at like a thousand miles
how painful must there's a frame missing
with each loop Wow yeah for bringing
that
that was a good one that's a great clip
yes fantastic you guys fix the logo you
took the white part out we do
yeah it looks better yeah okay okay so
for this one this was a Halloween when
we all kind of debuted our costumes here
this is a great job okay Oh j-just
gloves do they fit are they too small on
you they're too big they're too big I
don't know what that means
well oj is obviously an alleged murderer
he was acquitted in court but he did
lose in civil court so I think we can
all pretty much make a informed decision
that he is a murderer
good for you you love now I want to show
up you want to you guys want to come
make an appearance too cuz your guys is
your outfits are let's cut the Zac so
cuz he can't really move oh my god you
guys amazing this was all you guys yeah
yeah so it was like oh can we appreciate
that you have an authentic brazo poster
yeah that's amazing
Dan brother it was a I'm so anxious now
there
so I feel like the gaze of mere code
straight am I saying a little lip twitch
you want to read what's on the sign
behind you is pretty funny mm-hmm go
ahead come on every time you turn off I
get anxious I'm gonna read it for Zach
you shouldn't from me looking like a
thousand percent damn what do we got
from you Brad that's such a perfect
shirt that's perfect is that raw and
then we had where's the ring clicking on
the glass then you have to scream like a
like you know a dying animal because you
do look really good cuz you look when I
saw down other employee you want to do
the line this is definitely me when I'm
on camera anyways the Halloween
Oh fantastic effort we talked about
little Nos this was actually sound by
origin as well I played my edit Ethan
was very impressed yo I got it
I really gotta tap your editing skills
Wow we go back I didn't realize that was
the origin of that moment I got to tap
your editing skills this year I'm gonna
make a HD video and IANS gonna edit it
you walk that was part of the conditions
of you becoming an employee was that in
the contract
no but as as a result of that then there
was kind of this whole thing where you
had beef with rapper little Tracy is
little Tracy a big deal he's like
popular he's got a cult fanbase why did
you tell me to keep my name out of your
mouth grandpa you don't remember
no he's John rabe and we were talking
about like how do people were doing
similar things so we are saying that if
Old Town Road seemed like a ripoff of
little Tracy and I said no yeah you said
little Tracy was like he needed to just
deal with it okay and then he called you
a grandpa he's awesome he's 23 and
to his twitter solaris and i rebooted
him as i loved one of his doggy
let's check am i him rat beef right now
[Laughter]
yeah I have to get a more beef with the
more rappers this year oh yeah this is
the year beef yeah you're the beef and
then worse worse let's not forget it's
time to the contract is not in fact a
good faith effort yes okay and we both
agree that he will be the arbiter of
this agreement okay deal
accept okay but rather must be hard upon
wrote this contract to this country yeah
not dependent on stabilized Astros or
glower stable what are we talking about
what's the context you guys stop talking
about everything if I eat mayonnaise The
Bachelor yeah The Bachelor segment yeah
the contract is still about on all
points mostly remain here - that's so is
it just the way that it did this for you
or in retrospect the bachelor the whole
thing is just got dicey you're arguing
like every week stressful for me it
wasn't really I liked the process I
thought it was entertaining I think you
went behind our backs and ruined the
[ __ ] show because you found true love
what are you throwing out all right
I forgot we made you eat mail so to make
payment for the contracts hey a bunch of
mayo and yeah and so we gave him this
tiny little jar but you actually well
let's watch
oh I closed it no but tell me about the
process you ate a bunch of it you didn't
made a valiant effort yeah and then
afterwards not walk me through that you
guys left this was like about an hour
and a half later we were doing the
highlights and then I
ran off to the bathroom and same thing
Zack said where'd that you feel the
taste as it comes out yeah and then that
makes more come out and the way it look
like and then in the in the bowl I I
think I said it looked like like like
the Stay Puft Marshmallow Man was like
murdered in that bad like a crime scene
the thing you guys do for the show a lot
of mayo related worsts last year was
very male let's make last year the year
the male yeah
but ya know the whole segment got dicey
so it was my worst but kind of also my
best ultimately yeah let me ask you this
question shall we continue this series
The Bachelor because we have a candidate
so we'd reveal the candidate yeah
something you guys should we do another
season I think so I thought it was great
what what you tinge has reserves tell me
it was it was a disaster last time yeah
we got true love at the end well that
was the problem is cuz and now you guys
get why I was so I was fighting you on
that because I like new when I was
talking to this person that I was like
oh this is the person and then I didn't
want it you know that was kind of a I
understand that yeah I could feel it and
so that was the struggle but I talked to
the person who you're considering for
mm-hmm and they seemed like I'm down
there and they're willing they're
definitely a fully willing participant
yeah well first of all I didn't want
conservative feel like it was
entertaining okay that's doing and
second of all I love we do I do the
drama is great well anyway the person I
think we already said is Ellis brother
he's a he's a little bit older right
then in so it'll be interested to see
what kind of candidates will get because
he's he's 43 or something right not
gonna improve him dating someone too
young what 43 is that right deal he's
something like that 42 he's very
successful
he drives a Porsche
he's he looks youthful he's
extraordinary successful he's very
talented extremely talented artist nice
much like the current bachelor he was a
pilot too right that's true good point
anyone who's watching The Bachelor so
what's the cutoff then if he's less age
42 what 30 30 is a good color I mean
over 30 I would even say I hate to do
this to you but I'll say 28 I think 30
because if you're 28 you're pretty
mature I feel like okay 28 or not 28
okay
28 you said he's 42 yeah that whole I
mean not that this is like a real thing
but there's that whole formula well yeah
what is the formula it's supposed a half
your age plus 7 which would be 28 oh wow
the formula 28 felt good to me so I
think we got to do it I think we should
why don't we start let's pull up a
picture of him so that we need to
formally announce this with some
capacity but I mean this is buried yeah
yeah this is buried you said you talked
to him in his he's in he's like do we
get to film the dates yeah of course man
that's the whole point we never got that
far with you he looks like Jesus and his
name is Moses let's see some picture
where's a nice photo of him not that
this one's weird do the one that one
this one's great because he actually
played Jesus yeah this is his art by the
way the water
did alright what about the want the
water there you can get a good look at
him what this one no up and look to the
left this one yeah
wow that's a good one of him I wanted to
show where was it oh they go on the left
look at this Jesus say he's gonna save
your soul so there you go I just Jim so
that's Moses we call them holy Moses
those that know him best call him Chico
for short oh you can't call him Chico I
mean I just wouldn't really introduce
him by that name Moses yeah Moshe
in Hebrew yeah holy Moses holy Moses we
call him I guess I guess people if they
want you know if they want to first of
all show interest include and from email
us at podcast at h3 reproduction comm
include your name your age where you
live we need photos we need a little bit
about yourself I mean come on we're date
this is dating do we want to limit it to
LA because less than No
okay she isn't your girl your true love
is not no they yeah that's true no we
don't want to live it totally we take
all applicants you in the country though
and you're not international application
Canada else except Canada that's pretty
close yeah I accept Canada although
that's that's complicated you know cuz
if they do fall in love how they gonna
make that work 90 day fiancé
yeah yeah okay Canada's accepted that's
we get our arse far spin-off yeah so
we'll have to talk about this again on
Friday to make sure we penetrate the
masses cuz like Dan said nobody's
watching yeah well that's it right yeah
that's it 2019 was a hell of a year I
think you guys you guys are the best I
can do without you guys we have so
already some two exciting guests on the
book also Gus Johnson yeah we have Gus
coming up why don't we announced
calendar whatever you know we got them
we got next week is next week is
PewDiePie PewDiePie Thursday and then I
think Gus is Friday I think we Friday
okay yeah John's right around the corner
ah yeah that's the following week yeah
and then a little bit further out I
don't think we have it locked down quite
yet but Oliver tree is coming back right
for another visit and then there's a few
others on the work but uh but yeah those
are the only ones that are like
confirmed one so far said good good
stuff on the horizon yeah absolutely
well guys that rats a wrap for today so
we'll see you on Friday or well Saturday
I keep [ __ ] that up we record on
Friday we upload on Saturday and we'll
see you then so until then be good stay
good to your mother be good to your
mother huh don't don't make me don't
make me what did you say are you out of
your rabid-ass mind come on I got a call
from your mother yeah I don't want to
hear from your mother again alright
alright guys take care of Tata
[Music]
[Music]